lo que tenemos aquí es la gráfica de
hebe igual al seno de dos veces teta en
coordenadas polares y si las coordenadas
polares te parecen completamente
desconocidas o necesitas un repaso de
ellas te encargo que busques coordenadas
polares en khan academy o le eches un
vistazo a la sección de pre cálculo pero
te voy a dar un pequeño repaso por aquí
para que nos familiaricemos con él
porque esta gráfica se ve de esta manera
lo que estamos haciendo para cada punto
de esta gráfica bueno sabemos que
podemos ver cada punto en términos de
coordenadas x y james pero también
podemos especificar los en términos de
un radio y de un ángulo así que por
ejemplo este punto podemos decir que
tiene una coordenada xy una coordenada
james o podemos trazar una recta desde
el origen hasta ese punto y especificar
que para un cierto ángulo theta tenemos
un cierto radio r que es la distancia
antes del origen hasta ese punto y sólo
para familiarizarnos con esta curva
veamos por qué esto es intuitivo
cuando teta es igual a cero r es igual a
cero porque es el seno de cero que es
cero así que está r está en el origen y
si te empieza a crecer r empieza a
crecer así que empezamos a trazar este
primer pétalo o esta primera hoja de
este trébol o como quieras verlo y nos
vamos a mantener creciendo hasta que
lleguemos a theta igual a pi cuartos qué
va a pasar cuando te estás igual a pi
cuartos bueno estamos justo aquí y si
observas tenemos el seno de dos veces pi
cuartos que es igual al seno de pi
medios que es lo mismo que uno así que
parece que llegamos a un valor máximo
allí y después de ese valor nuestro
radio r parece que ahora está
decreciendo de nuevo bien ahora vamos a
pensar esto en términos del cálculo así
que la primera pregunta que seguramente
te harás es cómo puedo expresar mi tasa
de cambio de r con respecto a theta
pausa el vídeo e intenta encontrar
cuánto vale r prima de teta
bueno realmente no hay nada nuevo aquí
tenemos una variable como función de la
otra así que simplemente podemos usar la
regla de la cadena para tomar la
derivada con respecto a theta por lo
tanto la derivada con respecto a teta
va a ser dos en homs de dos veces este
está ok ya esto hay que multiplicarlo
por la derivada de dos tetas lo cual es
simplemente dos así que pondré el 2 al
principio multiplicando ahora pensemos
en cómo podemos expresar esta curva en
términos de x y de yes y después
pensemos en sus respectivas derivadas ok
regresemos al repaso de pre cálculo
ahora si queremos pasar el mundo polar
al mundo digamos rectangular entonces
tenemos que recordar las
transformaciones siguientes james es
igual
r por el seno de teta y la otra que es x
es igual a r por el coseno de teta ahora
porque esto tiene sentido bueno tomemos
algunas de nuestras combinaciones de
radio y ángulo digamos que esta es
nuestra teta y que ésta es nuestra era
entonces la longitud de este lado va a
ser nuestra yema y la longitud de este
otro lado será nuestra equis pero
sabemos por nuestras definiciones del
círculo unitario es decir por
trigonometría por las definiciones del
shock actúa de nuestras funciones
trigonométricas que el seno de teta es
igual al cateto opuesto entre la
hipotenusa por lo tanto el seno de teta
en este caso es igual a g / r
que es nuestra hipotenusa y el coste de
beteta es igual a bueno x / ere y ahora
si simplemente multiplicamos a ambos
lados de esta ecuación por r obtenemos
nuestras expresiones para x y para james
en términos de ere y de teta una vez más
si esto se te hace muy rápido o confuso
recuerda que esto es simplemente un
repaso de coordenadas polares de nuestra
sección de pre cálculo y ahora podemos
usar estas dos para expresar el jr y x
en términos simplemente de teta y como
hacemos eso bueno ya sabemos que r es
igual al seno de dos tetas entonces
podemos reemplazar estas eres por el
seno de dos teta y entonces me quedaría
aquí que es igual al seno de dos tetas
que es lo que vale esta r por el seno de
teta ok
y x es igual al seno de dos tetas que es
lo que vale la renta por el seno del tc
perfecto ahora podemos usar estas dos
expresiones para encontrar la tasa de
cambio de james con respecto a teta y de
x con respecto a teta pausa el vídeo e
intenta encontrar estas derivadas bien
vamos a trabajarlo juntos ok ahora
usemos nuestras técnicas sobre las
derivadas vamos a escribir a prima de
teta y usar la regla del producto la
derivada de esta expresión de rojo bueno
ya la sabemos es dos veces el coseno de
dos tetas eso está escrito acá arriba y
como vimos hace rato sale de la regla de
la cadena y a esto habrá que
multiplicarlo por la segunda expresión
que es simplemente el seno de teta ya
esto hay que sumarle la primera
expresión que es el seno de dos teta y
multiplicarlo por la derivada de la
segunda expresión que es la derivada del
seno de teta que es conocernos de teta
entonces esto por coseno de teta
y ahora hagamos lo mismo para x x prima
de teta es igual a la derivada de la
primera expresión que es dos veces con
seno de dos tetas eso ya lo vimos por la
segunda expresión tal cual está que es
el co seno de teta ya esto hay que
sumarle la primera expresión tal cual
está que es el seno de dos teta y
multiplicarlo por la derivada de la
segunda expresión la derivada del coche
no de teta es igual al menos seno de eta
entonces le cambiaremos el signo y nos
quedan menos seno de dos teta por el
seno de teta y de hecho podemos usar
esto para evaluar algunos puntos podemos
decir qué pasa cuando teta es igual a pi
cuartos
ok vamos a ponerlo en color negro para
que resalten estaríamos justo aquí en
este punto
pues vamos a evaluar las derivadas y
tengo que prima de pi cuartos va a ser
igual a dos veces el coseno de dos por
tres cuartos lo cual es pri medios ok
por el seno de pi cuartos ok ya esto hay
que sumarle el seno de m2 por pi cuartos
lo cual es pri medios el seno de pi
medios por él coseno de pitt cuartos ya
cuántos igual esto bueno sabemos que el
coste no de medios es igual a cero
entonces todo esto se cancela y luego
tengo el seno de pi medios que es igual
a 1 y el coseno depp y cuartos que es
igual a la raíz de 2 entre 2 entonces
simplemente me queda que todo esto es
igual a la raíz de dos entre dos y de
hecho para ahorrar espacio mejor
marquemos que esta es la respuesta de ye
prima detectan cuando teta es igual a pi
cuartos
ahora podemos hacer lo mismo para equis
y decir x prima evaluada en pi cuartos
me va a quedar 2 por el coseno de pi
medios lo cual es 0 por lo tanto el
primer sumando va a ser el mismo
simplemente será 0 ok entonces quitemos
lo menos el seno de pi medios por el
seno de pi cuartos déjame escribirlo con
su respectivo color el seno de dos veces
pi cuartos es el seno de pri medios por
el seno de pi cuartos ahora el seno de
pi medios este de aquí es simplemente
uno y el seno de pi cuartos eso es lo
mismo que la raíz de dos sobre dos así
que con este menos me va a quedar que
expriman evaluada en teta igual a pi
cuartos es igual a menos raíz de dos
entre dos y ahora veamos porque esto
tiene sentido pensemos en lo que pasa
cuando te tan crece por aquí bien veamos
si aumentamos nuestro ángulo teta de pi
cuartos a algo
un poco más grande observa nuestra
coordenada james sigue creciendo y esto
tiene sentido porque tenemos una
pendiente positiva y ahora qué le pasa a
nuestra coordenada x bueno observa
mientras theta aumenta un poco nuestra x
decrece y es por eso que tiene sentido
tener una tasa de cambio negativa y
bueno la segunda pregunta que te puedes
hacer es ok ahora quiero encontrar la
tasa de cambio de con respecto a x
porque quiero encontrar la pendiente de
mi recta tangente cómo puedo encontrarla
bueno parece que tengo por aquí observa
una pendiente de menos 1 pero cómo
podemos calcularla bueno una forma de
pensarlo es la siguiente sabemos que la
derivada de con respecto a x bueno esto
es igual a la derivada de con respecto a
theta entre la derivada de x con
respecto a teta y en este valor que
estamos calculando cuando te estás igual
a pi cuartos bueno esto va a ser igual a
la derivada de con respecto a x
es lo mismo que primero tengo la
derivada de ye con respecto a theta lo
cual es raíz de 2 sobre 2 y después de
hace que la derivada de x con respecto a
teta es menos raíz de 2 entre 2 y bueno
esto se simplifica y simplemente me
quedan menos 1 lo cual tiene sentido se
puede observar que la pendiente de mi
recta tanger está aquí es de menos 1 así
que espero que todo esto te haya ayudado
espero que poner todo junto te haya
hecho sentir un poco más cómodo tuvimos
un pequeño repaso sobre las coordenadas
polares pero aumentamos nuestro
conocimiento aprendiendo a tomar algunas
derivadas continuaremos en el siguiente
vídeo hasta pronto